two flags sovereign equals
face-to-face once more because the most
intractable issue of brexit
northern ireland has reared its head
again
smiles but little warmth the eu's say
we're
breaking a promise to track goods from
britain to northern ireland brexit
minister david frost
says eu demands are carving up the
united kingdom
the problem we've got is that the
protocol is being implemented in a way
which is causing disruption in northern
ireland and we had some pretty frank and
honest discussions about that situation
today
there weren't any breakthroughs there
aren't any breakdowns either
and we're going to carry on talking what
we really now need to do is
very urgently find some
the eu's chief negotiator today laid
down an important marker
we are at the crossroads in our
relationship with the uk
trust which should be at the heart of
every partnership
needs to be restored our patients really
is
very very very thin and therefore we
have to assess
all options we have at our disposal
why do the eu insist on intensive checks
on goods between britain
and northern ireland do you understand
why some people really struggle with the
idea that the eu single market is
genuinely at risk because there aren't
intensive checks on
mincemeat going from britain to northern
ireland supermarket we don't know what's
actually happening
at the border therefore there is the
anxiety
that the public health is at risk
and therefore we insist that they should
be corrected and
the checks should be done properly to
avoid the very real prospect of a trade
war
all sides must back down the only way to
solve the tensions evolving brexit in
northern ireland
will be for all size to take a step back
from the brink
ambiguity has long been the key to
easing tensions in northern ireland
that's why today felt like it went
backwards there were warnings
threats and hard deadlines
what tools might the eu use to punish
the uk
then the eu would be able to initially
fine
and place fines against the uk and move
on potentially to imposing tariffs
against the uk and even suspending parts
of the agreement
uh with the uk so they have a number of
tools in that
framework at their disposal these are
words
many hope they'd never hear again what
are we gonna do with the eu today
talks continue sam coates sky news